what if all the stars disappeared
tomorrow together with all the planets
solar systems and galaxies what would be
left of the universe if it suddenly
collapsed what could make it restart its
cosmic cycle all over again
and how exactly could the entire
universe break apart this is what if and
here's what would happen if the universe
ended tomorrow some fifty million years
from now the Martian moon Phobos will
slam into Mars and shatter to pieces in
100 million years earth will likely get
hit by an asteroid the size of the one
that caused all the dinosaurs to go
extinct in about one and a half billion
years the Sun will become so luminous
that it will force the habitable zone to
move outwards leaving what's left of
Earth to get crispy everything will
eventually come to an end even our
almost 14 billion year old universe what
would it be like to witness the epic end
of the cosmos don't get too comfy the
end of the universe would mean the end
of everything in it two trillion
galaxies that we can observe from Earth
filled with a tremendous amount of
everything from enormous gas giants to
weird shape asteroids everything would
be gone including you and whoever else
is out there but your last moments could
be very different depending on how the
universe shut down here are three ways
it might happen one possibility is it
might get really chilly the universe is
expanding galaxies are moving away from
each other at an ever-increasing rate
despite the attempts of gravity to pull
them back together that's because a
theoretical force called dark energy is
opposing the force of gravity if one day
this dark energy pulled a little too
hard the pieces of raw material needed
for star formation would become too far
away from each other all the existing
stars would eventually run out of fuel
and there would be no new ones to
replace them it would get very dark and
very cold
once the temperature reached absolute
zero nothing would be able to move not a
single atom the universe would become
the most boring static place and would
probably remain an endless void forever
I bet you were hoping for a more
spectacular ending to this story so
let's add more action with the big rip
if the dark energy became so intense
that it was able to nullify the force of
gravity altogether it would rip the
universe apart it would start with the
galaxies tearing them down one by one
black holes would be the next to
disintegrate followed by stars planets
asteroids as the expansion of the
universe ramped up every form of matter
would collapse on itself and decay into
radiation that of course includes you
the universe would end up full of single
particles would it ever come together
after its death let's try our luck with
the Big Crunch theory if the force of
gravity fought back hard enough to
overthrow the dark energy the universe
would stop expanding it would shrink
back instead planets would collide with
other planets the stars would slam into
each other galaxies would merge together
earth wouldn't be able to dodge all the
space matter for too long the universe
would compress into a very dense
singularity just the way it was before
the Big Bang began spewing up galaxies
from that singularity it could make a
fresh cosmic start with new planets new
stars new life forms one way or another
the universe and everything in it will
end but it won't happen in just one day
we still have time to become a more
advanced civilization and maybe even
find a cozy exoplanet to settle on but
that's a story for another what if
[Music]